please welcome brain games master
mentalists Lior sushar world renowned
medalist Lee or su shard has wowed
crowds around the planet with his
amazing powers can he define some
personal details from Kristen and Dax
let's find out how long do you know each
other 12 years 12 years phase in love
they love each other yeah how many
people you would say here would know the
name of your first crush zero zero zero
okay yeah oh wow no it's not can you
just tell me what was your age back then
that's it only your age 11 11 so can you
say the ABC really quickly your Labour's
ABC real quickly the ABCD efg hijk LMNOP
qrs tuv wxyzi don't know if this means
is it a common name it's not no wait a
second not where we go you doing this
why did you say what's the name what was
the name my mouth is so dry what was the
name of your first crush great
Cori
[Applause]
I know I just can't wait
homie if you're watching us right now
you blow at Kristen I don't I don't
and I can't I'm trying to figure it out
and they won't tell me he's a witch
that's what I said we're standing in
front of a Dark Presence it's always
addresses in white lies he has the devil
dresses like a fallen angel it's a true
what was your age when you had your
first crush
just I'm gonna go around the 8th a 8
yeah 8 years of age as I said quick
develop I see nothing can you say the
ABC real quickly
ABCD efg hijk LMNOP qrs tuv this is
difficult because you are thinking it's
kind of weird kind of a longer name than
Cory but I'm not sure so I'm just gonna
go with what I feel okay
I'm prepared to die if you get it right
oh boy oh that's the name right I did
say today that the name yes it is what
was the name age 8 what was the name
Elizabeth
oh wait
what no no you don't Lea or well you
don't what to me
what's her initials e G we need to we
have ten seconds before he takes over
the universe I think I even knew see
this is this is she doesn't know it I
barely knew it no one knows it he knows
it he didn't even know he liked
Elizabeth Jim I guess where R is the key
to my Lincoln I've not been able to find
of her mind
[Applause]
[Music]